Bởi vì tháng 24, các hình thái phẩy năm triệu trẻ giới sống tuổi.
Thương tá về một triệu người từ sáo cho đến người táng tuổi và hình thái mức phẩy sáo cho người trên người táng tuổi.
Bộ mấy hai đều phương đặt tỷ lệng lưu rất đường cám sức khỏe trên năm 2020.
Trong đó đồng tháp rất đồng, với mấy hai phẩy táng phần trọng.
Thếp đến lạc cám ảo, tháng quyền, đặc lắc lập đồng và phủ thọng.
Trong khi đó thì chính địa phương có tỷ lệ giới hai mình phần trọng của vũn vinh lòng linh vình tuần quanh tương viên tháng nốt thành phố Hồ Chí Minh,
Anh Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang, Giang bảo gạo tháng mấy,
thì hơn 2 triệu lực khám được thực hiện tại trạp y tế cấp sả, vân một phẩy chính triệu lực khám lưu đậc,
và hơn 1 phẩy sáo triệu lực khám tại các cơ sở khám triệu bệ khác.
Đến anh thì đạc có hơn 3 về tảm chiệu người được lập sổ sức khỏe để tự, theo bộ y tế thì quá trình trên khai vẫn còn nhiều khó khám.
Một số địa phương cho biết là hệ thống văn bản hướng dẫn chưa được bộ thời gian trình bị hắn trong khi một số chính quyền cấp sả chưa phát quy tầy đủ và cho chỉ đạo hay lập hội.
Dự đợp vương thì vẫn đang xây dữ kế hoạch hoặc trên khai chất hơn sau biểu cầu.
Còn khám lần nhất là tiểu bác xí và nhìn đi tế nhất là tại dưới cơ sở vùng sau phủng xa,
các giờ bật chất chăng thiết bị và hạ tần công nghệ thông tin còn tiểu và anh vường đến việc thật nhất dữ liệu.
Mình cách đó thì một bộ phẩn người dân vẫn chưa hình thành thói quen khám xế khỏe để kì trong khi biến đậm dân kư và lâu động dịch,
thì cũng về khó khám trong việc lập dân sách cũng nhiều huy động người dân tham gia khám.